and he said I made a mistake doing that
I'm having a lot of trouble now because
I've achieved my goals what is your
daily hardest you know hustle all day
long
dropping out mmm no way to every man of
woman born death cometh soon or late you
know money can't solve all the problems
it won't put back the rainforest back
when it's clear-cut like if you want to
be an Olympic swimmer or an Olympic
osmond you have to practice all the time
I need to cover success magazine I held
a copy up the day I said dad is that
enough I'm on the cover of Success
Magazine you know he's an American media
mogul and philanthropist as a
businessman he's known as the founder of
CNN the first 24-hour all-news TV
station he has an estimated net worth of
2.2 billion dollars
he's Ted Turner and here is my take on
his top ten rules for success my
personal favorite is rule number three
and I'm curious if you grew it which one
you guys like the best my father told me
what when I was a small boy did he
strongly recommended I set my goal so
high that I couldn't achieve in my
lifetime because he had he had set his
goals oh he said go after the depression
that he would be a millionaire and have
a got in a plantation and he had a small
plantation and he had a small yacht and
he was a millionaire and he couldn't all
refocuses his life and he said I made a
mistake doing that I'm having a lot of
trouble now because I've achieved my
goals and he said please set your goals
so high that you can't achieve them so
I'm trying to help save the world and I
think that's probably you know higher
than I buy I don't anticipate achieving
it completely but I would like to how
early in life did you
you relentless ambition begin did this
happen when you were very young you've
you alluded to the fact that you sold
papers at age six or something well I
don't know it just all I don't really
feel like I'm that ambitious
oh come on I'd hate to follow you around
for a week yeah well I just beat your
card but I know a lot he would work hard
my father worked hard and set an example
for me and all and I know a lot of
people that work hard what does it mean
working hard what is your daily heart is
you no hustle all day long you know we
talked about hustlers Pete grows on the
baseball field I try and do that all day
long and that's what I think we need to
do here in America I mean the people
working in the American automobile
industry we got our Fussell with
Japanese we've got to get that old roll
up our sleeves and get back to work man
we'll get this country out of trouble we
can do anything better than anybody else
in the world that's your life there's
nobody we got a real wake-up Irit that's
what I try and do with the Atlanta
Braves is get everybody hustling because
it's it sets a good example of the
people that are watching the program you
want enough what made you
single-handedly decide to replenish
America's bison herd
save everything remember
I'm supposed to be shooting for
something that's impossible to to have
happen in my lifetime and he has done
the impossible many times like the 1979
Fastnet race off the coast of England a
massive storm whipped up winds and waves
that left 15 sailors dead to this day
it's considered the most dangerous ocean
race ever and Ted didn't just survive he
won and that's where we started our
conversation about his amazing life was
there ever a moment that you thought you
wouldn't make it no but I didn't spend a
whole lifetime thinking about not making
it I was trying to figure out how to
keep going were you afraid no did you
ever think of not going through with the
race was it ever a topping out mmm no
way every night dropping out with seeing
in the lines that on courage because if
you're gonna be successful in business
you got to have a lot of courage then
step forward Horatius this is from
Horatius at the bridge by Thomas
Macaulay then step forward to race the
captain of the gate he said to every man
of woman born death cometh soon or late
and how can man die better than facing
fearful odds for the ashes of his
father's and the temples of his gods hew
down the bridge sir counseled with all
the speedy Bay I would but too beside me
will hold the phone and play on yon
narrow span a thousand might well be
stopped by three now who will stand on
either hand and guard the bridge with me
pretty strong they stopped the whole
Etruscan art you know money can't solve
all the problems it won't put back the
rainforests back when it's clear-cut but
money can solve a lot of problems Turner
put his money where his mouth is
Thursday night pledging a billion
dollars to the United Nations over the
next
ten years if you're working to help
others
I'll make the world better you'll be a
lot happier than if all you're doing is
trying to make things better for
yourself you know if you're a selfish
person I think selfish people are not as
happy as generous people for instance
because the real greatest joy and
satisfaction of all I think is is
helping others I think the old biblical
phrase it's more blessed to give than
receive is absolutely true and well you
know I gave away so far close to about
half of what I had then that made me
feel real good I'd like to see us all
living in peace and harmony and most of
us are you know most of us are living in
peace in harmony we could all be if we
just stole almost all of us if we just
put a little more effort into it and I'm
going to keep working on it the company
is called Turner and they got rid of
Turner did you ever imagine in your
wildest dreams that that would happen no
no that's that's a mistake I made
will you ever get over it no I don't
have to get over time I live with it you
know at least I haven't had this serious
bout of cancer I've got a little skin
cancer but you know you've got to be got
to be able to take some disappointment
in life to not always is everything
going to go going to go well so you just
have to roll with the punches when when
adversity it's you how did you ignore
all those naysayers and continue to sort
of blaze the trail of all 90 95 % of all
new ventures fail so if you just bet
against all new ventures odds they're
90% you're going to be right 90% of the
time but you're going to miss that 1 out
of 1 out of 10 or 1 out of 20 chances to
to really hit a home run and I wasn't
worried about the naysayers saying it
wasn't going to work I just I just
laughed about it because I knew it was
and he worked very hard at it is well I
wasn't going to let it fail and even if
you read my book it's right there that I
wasn't going to let it fail and I'm not
going to let all I'm not going to let
humanity fail to get rid of nuclear
weapons and and and and and handle this
energy thing I'm going to keep fighting
till till we start getting it right I
also was tired the one thing that did
happen to me I mean I worked 18 hours a
day seven days a week
when I owned the Braves and the Hawks I
went to almost every game and I watched
the away games on television - even the
ones from the West Coast it came on at
ten o'clock at night and went till 3:00
in the morning and and and most people
you know I went to work at 8:00 or 8:30
in the morning and I lived in my office
so I didn't have to draw
five and I lived in my office for
fifteen years and then it's six o'clock
when most people go home from work I had
to go over the ballpark and shake hands
and so I was working till 11 o'clock and
I'd go back to my office and sleep on my
couch and I did that every day for
20-something years and I got tired and
when you get tired though your judgments
not as good as if you stay fresh so one
thing I think I said in the book is so
if you decide you're really going to try
and go for it
like if you want to be an Olympic
swimmer or an Olympic osmond you have to
practice all the time you've got to give
up your whole life to do it basically
all and you've got to decide whether you
want to be the jack of all trades and
master of none or the master of one and
not so good at the rest and I decided I
wanted to be a world champion in sailing
and I wanted to be one of the best
businessman that ever lived and I tried
to do both and but it was and I wanted
to be a good father too so it's a lot
and not everybody could do it but I
tried my best to do it can you do
Shakespeare a little bit do you have
anything you'd like to defame on Honor
this is I think
Richard the third anyways one of the
Richards oh my honor is my life we live
in one take honor from me and my life is
done then pray my liege
my honor let me try for that I live and
for that well I die
and I live with that it's not one
blemish on my honor in my entire 76 year
career
not once how many times have you heard
protesters saying get rid of Turner's
you know corruption no nothing never
paid anybody off never and and in the
news business there were times when
putting a little money on the table
would get you some access that you
wouldn't get otherwise there it's very
easy to slip into corruption
very easy but I resisted it all the way
long not not one time when I look back
at all my business accomplishments CNN
was the most exciting and most most
challenging and the most satisfying one
when we were successful because you know
I got proven right I was Time Magazine's
a person of the year for the whole world
I mean that's you know what more could
you do to that I need to cover Success
Magazine I held a copy up the day I said
dad is that enough I'm on the cover of
Success Magazine you know so whoa you
know and then then we had the AOL merger
so it didn't last very long and I was
down and out again one of the worst
mistakes it's ever been made in business
we went into it half-cocked and
unprepared and that that's something you
don't want to do on a merger of that
consequence you know you want to really
be careful when you're dealing with
billions and billions of dollars and the
careers of literally thousands of people
that were you know their life savings
was wiped out - I had some doubts and I
voiced them and I talked to the best
people I could for advice and they felt
like it there there was no way I could
have stopped it so I went along with it
be a good soldier and and I lost uh
eighty percent of my money I lost my job
at CNN and Turner Broadcasting at that
same time Jane Fonda and I got a divorce
and I lost the grandchild that passed
away and so I was really down and I had
two choices one you either go down which
I plenty of excuses for but I didn't
want to go down I I still felt like I
had contributions to make and I just
gritted my teeth and said I'm gonna come
out of this they don't like Scarlett
O'Hara I did at the end of the first
half of Gone with the Wind members shoot
so standing up on the hill as the camera
went back and she said as God is my
witness I'll never be hungry again you
know that such as God is my witness I'm
gonna get through this and and I'm going
to make a comeback thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because mr. forced in' asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur you want
me to profile next leaving the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I also
love to know what you have Ted Turner's
rules and clips meant the most to you
and why leave it in the comments and I
will join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon